mehrmals am tag spielt sich etwas sehr
merkwürdiges im herzen von genf ab nicht
so schlimm
stellen sie sich auf die waage dutzende
von menschen vor allem frauen warten auf
das wiegen und das anschließende urteil
aber sie haben 900 gramm verloren schön
wir sind bei weight watchers dem
führenden globalen schlankheits institut
mit 1 5 milliarden franken umsatz und
über einer million kunden weltweit davon
10.000 in der schweiz
hier ist eine top figur maßstab aller
dinge doch ist dieses versprechen seriös
oder nur eine art wunder rezept für
unsere recherchen begleiten wir eine
gruppe von kandidaten beim abnehmen mit
der bewilligung von oberster stelle
karin gilt als der beste weibliche coach
der schweiz
wenn ihr genug ausdauer habt werdet ihr
euer idealgewicht sicher erreichen
ein ganzes jahr lang folgen wir den
kandidaten werden sie es schaffen
abzunehmen und ihre traumfigur zu
erlangen
[Musik]
in der gruppe von carin treffen wir drei
teilnehmer die gewicht verlieren wollen
marie hat bereits 16 kilo weniger und
will noch weitere 15 abnehmen
ich hatte nie probleme nicht hübsch zu
machen doch als die wagen er zeigte dass
mein gewicht stieg und stieg bis zu
dreistelligen zahlen
da wusste ich dass ich etwas tun musste
102 kilo der nie wird bald in rente
gehen er hat gemerkt dass seine figur
nicht mehr so ist wie in seiner jugend
sein ziel 20 kilo abnehmen
wir haben letztes jahr am strand ein
video gedreht nicht gefühle überhaupt
nicht da sagte ich mir so nicht ich habe
keine lust die kunden attraktiv zu
werden
ich möchte doch etwas stiller und dann
emily sie hat genug von ihren kunden und
will unbedingt abnehmen doch das ist
nicht das erste mal vor ein paar jahren
hat die junge krankenschwester mit
weight watchers 15 kilo verloren doch
dann wurde sie schwanger und nahm wieder
zu sogar ein paar kilo mehr als vorher
dennoch hat sie ihr vertrauen in die
methode nicht verloren
ja ich möchte mich lieber weight
watchers anmelden
es sind immer noch meine kinos bei uns
richtig wir werden ihnen helfen
und sie motivieren sie zu erreichen mein
sohn ist schon größer und jetzt möchte
ich etwas für mich tun
ich möchte dass er stolz auf mich ist er
merkt wenn ich mich nicht gut fühle in
meiner haut ich weiß nicht wie es
herauskommt aber vielleicht käme ich
mich dann nicht mehr
er wird spüren dass seine mama
selbstbewusster wird das ist besser für
die familie
idealgewicht bei dem sie sich gut fühlen
ich möchte vorerst gute zehn kilo
abnehmen dann wird das schritt für
schritt ein erstes etappenziel wäre zehn
kilo
es gibt einen punkt und erreicht ich
weiß dass es nicht einfach ist
man muss sich auf kleine ziele
konzentrieren damit man nicht zu
enttäuscht ist und die motivation nicht
verliert ich beginne mit zehn kilo und
dann legen wir ein weiteres tief ist
wir werden ja sehen für emily findet
jede woche dasselbe ritual stadt erst
die waage dann das treffen mit den
anderen teilnehmern der preis 90 franken
im monat
zudem bietet weight watchers leichte
fertigmahlzeiten und kochbücher zum
verkauf
[Musik]
ich hoffe ihr habt gute erfolge auf der
waage erzielt das prinzip ist dasselbe
wie bei den anonymen alkoholikern
hier darf man im vertrauten kreis reden
karen heute coach war selbst auch einmal
kundin wo stehen sie beim abnehmen ich
stagnieren
der winter ist bald vorbei der frühling
kommt eine schwierige zeit was machen
wir marie und man kommt wieder zum
treffen sehr gut und man versucht sich
zu motivieren etwas in der ernährung zu
verändern zu diversifizieren
haben sie etwas ausprobiert was
christian helfen könnte
ich habe dieselben probleme auch ich
brauche hilfe
vielleicht hat jemand anders gute tipps
wo stehen sie morgens
ich habe 16 kilo verloren aber seit
langem stagniert mein gewicht
ich bin eigentlich sehr zufrieden denn
der weg dahin war lang und jetzt ist es
schwierig die motivation zu finden sind
die motivation wiederfinden die sie
hatten als sie das erste mal zur weight
watchers kamen ich ermutige sie sich ein
kleines ziel zu setzen und sich nicht
aufzugeben
ich betone noch einmal wenn alle es
schaffen 500 gramm zu verlieren bin ich
als coach überglücklich und somit sage
ich euch das war sehr sehr gut
donnerstagmittag haben wir 18,9 kilo
gewichtsverlust erreicht das sind
durchschnittlich 850 grad
das ist spitze
das war nicht ich nicht denn ich mache
nichts jene die zu diesem fantastischen
gewichtsverlust beigetragen haben wissen
sie werden sich freuen fröhlinger neues
bade klein zu kaufen nächste woche reden
wir über gute und leichte speisen auf
dem teller
ich wünsche euch eine wunderbare woche
diese frau die neidisch hat das konzept
von weight watchers in den 1960 er
jahren entwickelt sie war 107 kilo
schwer
nach mehreren erfolglosen diäten blut
sie freundinnen ein um mit ihnen
abzunehmen und sie schafft es
aufgrund dieser erfahrung gründete sie
die weight watchers
der erfolg war fulminant das unternehmen
eroberte die usa im sturm und
entwickelte sich zu einem weltweiten
imperium
die amerikanische marke schien das
wunder rezept gefunden zu haben die
zutaten zusammenkünfte mit einem coach
und ein punkte system welches das
kalorienzählen erleichtert also nur
regeln einhalten und garantiert abnehmen
weight watchers gibt sich als methode
bei der man essen darf und das gewicht
kontrollieren kann also keine diät in
paris treffen wir den psychiater jean
phillippe sam ap er ist spezialist für
fettleibigkeit und führt ein netzwerk
von 400 französischen ärzten und
ernährungsberatern die diäten ablehnen
er sagt ein zu schneller gewichtsverlust
könne zu organschäden führen und sei
sinnlos
man muss definieren was eine diät
überhaupt ist nur zu sagen das ist eine
diät und das nicht das geht nicht
der gemeinsame nenner aller methoden ist
die kontrolle wenn versucht wird die
ernährung bewusst zu kontrollieren
handelt es sich um eine diät weight
watchers mit seinem punktesystem ist
ganz klar eine kontrolle also eine diät
was wir heute wissen nach einem jahr
gelebt haben etwa 85 prozent der
personen gewicht verloren und nach drei
jahren diät haben 95 prozent wieder ihr
ausgangsgewicht diäten funktionieren
also nicht aus psychologischen und
physiologischen gründen
dies sagt die genfer psychologin magali
valerie seit jahren arbeitet sie mit
übergewichtigen personen bei jeder
beratung beginnt sie mit einer
grundlegenden aufklärung wenn man
zunimmt geschieht das auf zwei arten
entweder vermehren sich die fettzellen
das heißt wenn ich drei habe werden
sechs daraus oder die fettzellen werden
größer
wie es in lünen der geist büros und man
weiß nicht welcher prozess bei der einen
oder der anderen person stattfindet das
problem ist nur die vergrößerung der
fettzellen lässt sich rückgängig machen
wenn sich die vize informiert haben kann
ihre zahlen nicht mehr verringert werden
das bedeutet man kann nie mehr zumindest
gewicht zurückkehren
man kann zwar zehn prozent des gewichts
verlieren und so bleiben
mehr abnehmen ist wahrscheinlich
unmöglich über zehn kilo abnehmen und
das gewicht längere zeit halten wäre
also für die meisten 100 kilo schweren
menschen unmöglich
dennoch brüstet sich die weltweit
führende schlankheits organisation mit
spektakulären gewichtsreduktionen ihrer
kunden
man nennt diese gold karten mitgliedern
heute mit letizia ein wichtiges
etappenziel erreicht
wie fühlen sie sich ich habe meine
stabilisierung nach acht monaten mit
weight watchers beendet wie viele kilos
sind sie insgesamt 26
das gold kassenmitglied letizia darf
jetzt gratis an den kursen teilnehmen
wenn sie nicht wieder zunimmt
fotos vorher und nachher
ich habe sie auf facebook gepostet und
habe sehr viele antworten bekommen
dürfen wir sie sehen ich muss ihr es
finden und schlecht drei kleidergrößen
mindestens sie dürfen die anmeldung für
eine kandidatur als zukünftige weight
watchers muse ausführen jedes jahr gibt
es eine wahl wäre super wenn sie
gewinnen würden
spektakuläre erfolge wie der von
laetitia dienen der marke als werbung
sie werden zu temporären
aushängeschildern
jeder kann es schaffen coach karin weiss
aber dass diese verheißung grenzen hat
ich denke nicht dass das die mehrheit
betrifft das sind ausnahmen
vielleicht personen die ihre ernährung
ins gleichgewicht bringen mussten und zu
einem gewissen zeitpunkt ein paar tipps
brauchten um den wert der nahrungsmittel
zu erkennen sie sind so weight watchers
gekommen und haben diese tipps
verstanden
für menschen bei denen die
ernährungsprobleme tiefer sitzen mit
emotionen verbunden sind ist es
schwieriger karin ist überzeugt dass die
misserfolge auf mangelnden willen
zurückzuführen sind
ich glaube wir abnehmen und sein gewicht
halten will braucht einen starken willen
man muss sich ständig kontrollieren ich
arbeite vielleicht deswegen für weight
watchers
schoko der schwarze schokolade
vielleicht 27 seit dem morgen folgt
maria akribisch ihrem programm
sie muss ihr essen genau berechnen wenn
ich noch zurecht komme schaue ich im
internet und gebe die anzahl der weight
watchers punkte ein
wie viele punkte für kakaopulver bis
dreimal am tag also null punkte ich habe
das gefundene kleine beutel mit einer
genauen dosis ich habe gezählt wie viele
esslöffel haferflocken es sind also vier
punkte
es ist einfach rasch garantiert eine
gesunde ernährung und macht schnell satt
dass mit einem glas milch ist ein
frühstück mit sechs punkten
marjorie hat wir alle kunden des
amerikanischen unternehmens eine
tägliche punkte zahl die nicht
überschritten werden darf
die punkte sind genau nach ihrem gewicht
berechnet worden
jury hat 29 punkte pro tag gut
ihre jüngere schwester loren und ihre
beste freundin lara verfolgen ihren
kampf ich habe tee zubereitet wie war
deine woche gut ich habe 700 gramm
abgenommen
ich bin zufrieden es ist cool aber hört
ja im moment ist es schwierig ich habe
mühe bevor jura klett und schokolade
nicht zu kapitulieren
ich muss mich auf mein ziel
konzentrieren
20 kilo weniger an meinem geburtstag
also noch vier km jetzt ist februar und
es bleiben märz und april
das sollte klappen das verspricht weight
watchers 500 gramm pro woche
es ist schwierig du findest jene kleider
nicht die gier gefallen
das ist etwas frustrierend seine
kolleginnen kaufen viele sachen die für
dich nicht in frage kommen
du kriegst deine oberarme gar nicht rein
das war auch ein auslöser dafür dass ich
dir gesagt habe dass ich mit meinem
gewicht an der oberen grenze bin und
nicht mehr weiblich sein kann wie früher
das war sehr schwierig für mich es hat
mich total genervt
sie hatte sich nicht anmerken lassen wie
unwohl er war
sie benutzten begriff sich unwohl fühlen
da stimmt genau
es ist schwierig vor ihnen und der
kamera zu sprechen
nein hier schneiden wir ich möchte nur
verstehen warum es so schwierig ist
darüber zu sprechen weil wie schon
gesagt habe ich war immer das ist
schrecklich
ich war voller lebensfreude gepflegt und
trug gerne hübsche kleider aber wenn du
am abend nach hause kommst des spiegels
studieren nicht mehr gefällt das ist das
schwierigste überfordert ich das wenn du
dich kritisch betrachtet kann das brutal
sein eigenes urteil ist vielleicht
härter als wenn jemand auf der straße
sagt du seist du trotzdem bin ich im
alltag recht gut damit klargekommen bis
zu jenem punkt als es klick macht
ich konnte einfach nicht mehr obwohl man
es mir nicht angesehen hat
unangenehme blicke abschätzige
bemerkungen daran hat sich emily gewöhnt
im traum bleibt der platz neben ihr oft
leer in ihrer familie sind fast alle
übergewichtig als sie klein war musste
sie ihren teller leer essen auch wenn
sie nicht mehr hungrig war ihr mann gora
ist in senegal aufgewachsen bevor er in
die schweiz kam hatte er nie von weight
watchers gehört in senegal denken die
leute dass ihr glückliches mit mir weil
sie kurven hat man sieht das positiv man
findet einer frau mit rundungen gibt es
pläne
obwohl ich weiß dass die kultur hier
diktiert was als schön gilt und dass sie
wie die anderen sein möchte unterstütze
ich sie auf diesem weg damit sie sich
wohlfühlt das schlankheits diktat ist
für die diät firmen ein gefundenes
fressen sie verkaufen den traum von
einer top model figur für jede frau und
jeden mann
jenny macht nun seit vier monaten diät
und hat erst zwei kilo abgenommen
sie haben 100 gramm verloren immerhin
ich habe mir nicht besonders mühe
gegeben
warum ich war viel unterwegs in paris da
gab es versuche da fand ich aber
ziemlich schnell zwei kilo verloren
aber man hat nichts gesehen man muss
wirklich eine strecke disziplin
verfolger glaube wenn ich beim
schokoladenriegel nicht auf die punkte 8
wirkt sich das aus der nähe sträubt sich
gegen die kontrolle er möchte sich die
kleinen freuden nicht vermiesen lassen
mein problem ist der käse
es gibt zu viele sorten und ich lass
mich schnell verschieben
[Musik]
fribourg es ist absolut genial
meine kleine sünde er schmeckt etwas
muss ich da kann ich nicht widerstehen
ein stückchen jeden zweiten abend
münster
darum wie viel ist das 50 60 krank
das ist für später der nähe hat seine
eigene methode gesunder menschenverstand
er ist etwas weniger und vor allem
bewegt er sich mehr
ein bisschen habe ich abgenommen etwas
weniger bauch vorher war ich so aber ich
möchte auch hier abnehmen nicht wahr wie
es mühsam
am anfang habe ich mir gesagt ja ich
mache ein bisschen mit wenn ich abnehme
okay sonst ist es auch egal
aber wenn ich nicht abgenommen hatte
nervte mich dass dennoch ich habe mich
nicht gestimmt aber ich fand dass ich
das ziel nicht erreicht hatte
für marie ist das gewicht zur obsession
geworden
sie stellt sich am montag dienstag
mittwoch und sogar am donnerstag vor
ihrem treffen auf die waage und hofft
einige gramm abgenommen zu haben
ich merke sofort ob sie gewicht verloren
hat oder nicht
je nachdem wie sehr groß ist sie muss es
mir nicht mal sagen
diesmal war es nicht gut sie hatte ein
paar gramm zugenommen
seit ein paar tagen habe ich einfach
keine lust gemüse und fisch zu essen
ich habe lust auf schokolade fleisch und
wein und dann steht der hinterhand sagt
pass auf margerie wenn du das ist wirst
du es auf der waage sehen bietet mir
zwar nichts aber wenn er es tun würde
würde ich gleich das 2 3-fache essen in
der ersten zeit fühlt man sich gut weil
man bereit ist auf das gewicht zu achten
nach einer weile für die neue strikte
ernährungsweise das punkte zählen und
wegen der nahrungsmittel zu einer
zunehmenden frustration
das leben bringt würden und schwierige
situationen mit sich die man meistern
muss das macht die einhaltung der regeln
der einschränkungen viel schwieriger
weil openoffice seit kurzem hat marie
eine neue stelle
ihr tagesablauf ist durcheinandergeraten
sie kann sich nicht mehr auf das
ständige punkte zählen konzentrieren und
findet keine zeit mehr für die treffen
da waren geburtstage ich möchte wieder
weitermachen
ein bisschen 600 gramm
das geht es hätte schlimmer sein können
karin beschließt marjorie zu helfen
du darfst die motivation nicht verlieren
darum bin ich hier
du musst regelmäßige kommen auch wenn es
ein anderer tag eine andere zeit ist ich
will nicht wechseln ich möchte bei dir
bleiben nett von dir du musst an
idealgewicht erreichen
ja ich bin enttäuscht aber sich bei
weight watchers auf die waage zu stellen
ist nicht jedes mal befriedigend
schwierigsten ist es nicht da zu sein
wenn du abgenommen hast um zu kommen
wenn du weißt du hast zugenommen aber
davon profitiert du wenn du kommst hast
zugenommen
du wirst mit der realität konfrontiert
mit einem problem das bewirkt dass du
etwas tust damit es besser läuft
pausenlos gegen das gesicht zu kämpfen
karin weiß was das heißt wie alle
anderen coaches war auch sekunden bei
weight watchers vor ein paar jahren hat
sie 26 kilo abgenommen
doch aus sorge um ihre gesundheit hat
sie wieder 18 kilo zugelegt sie hat das
programm von neuem aufgenommen und die
18 kilo wieder verloren seit einem jahr
hält sie ihr gewicht
ich habe einen vertrag mit weight
watchers nach welchem ich mein
idealgewicht halten ich habe zwei kilo
toleranz sowie unsere kunden auf drei
bis vier mal im jahr müssen wir uns bei
der firmenleitung auf die waage stellen
wenn unser gewicht stimmt sehr gut wenn
nicht legt man uns nach wieder zu
unseren guten gewohnheiten zurück zu
kehren
heute ist ein wichtiger tag karin muss
auf die waage trotz ihrer täglichen
bemühungen geht sie besorgt zum treffen
der coaches in freiburg
ich bin am limit vielleicht meint es die
freiburger waage gut das ist immer etwas
schwieriger moment die konfrontation mit
unserem gewicht es ist das einzige was
heute ein bisschen stressig sein kann
die coaches kommen aus der ganzen
westschweiz und dem tessin wie für ihre
kunden beginnt das ganze mit der waage
kamen die regionalleiterin wiegt sie
hallodri yanar gute reise gehabt
guten tag herr in
das gilt coach die lage ist
ja super sie sind unsere vertreterinnen
wenn ihr gewicht stemmen ist das ein
gutes image für weight watchers hat sie
ihr gesicht
ich bin zufrieden alles ist gut die
frauen hier sind stolz wenn sie auf
ihrem gewicht sind wie sie sagen und
stolz darauf als coach auserwählt zu
sein aber auf die kleinste entgleisung
wird mit dem finger gezeigt carla kennst
du dein idealgewicht
ja das wäre 66 was ist seit dem letzten
mal geschehen da warst du noch im grünen
bereich
ich habe eine woche ferien im ausland
gemacht
eine hochzeit ein schöner tag doch alles
zu managen ist nicht leicht sein ziel
ist aber auch dein idealgewicht ja was
würdest du deinen kunden sagen
für die nächste woche ich werde mich ans
programm halten eine tägliche anzahl
punkte respektieren und auch darauf
achten dass ich meine körperliche
aktivität der fülle
da
[Musik]
sie könnte bis 68 zu nehmen aber jetzt
hat sie zwei kilo mehr sie ist viel kilo
über ihrem idealgewicht
man hat einen spielraum von zwei kilo
ich habe also zwei junge das ist immer
sehr heikel
man sagt sich das ist ja nicht sehr viel
aber wenn man das durch lässt und nicht
sagt sind sn drei wochen vielleicht wenn
es die hilft kannst du mir dein gewicht
jede woche mitteilen
es wird gehen bisher hat es auch
geklappt auch wenn sie mitfühlend wirkt
muss kamen ihre coaches an die
einhaltung der regeln erinnern calla
kommt mit einer ermahnung davon
doch die konsequenzen können
gravierender sein
in den usa der wiege der weight watchers
zeigt sich wie weit die marke gehen kann
in houston texas haben wir zwei
ehemalige coaches getroffen
heute ist george w
radiomoderator vorher hatte er vier
jahre lang für weight watchers
gearbeitet bis er kündigte enttäuscht
und wütend
er erzählt was er erlebt hat
nach einem treffen kamen ein paar neue
mitglieder herein und ich zeigte ihnen
dieses bild und sagte so habe ich
angefangen wo fanden sie unglaublich und
so sah ich aus als ich die meetings
führte dich nahm von 160 auf 90 kilo ab
dieses gewicht konnte ich ein jahr lang
halten
dann aber holte mich das leben ein ich
hatte nicht mehr so viel zeit und nahm
wieder zu
da begannen die probleme sie setzten
nicht wirklich unter druck
die gewichtskontrolle der coaches in den
usa ist noch rigoroser als die in der
schweiz
josh versuchte dem programm zu folgen
doch er nahm kilo um kilo wieder zu wir
mussten jeden monat auf dem burger und
unser gewicht musste konstant bleiben
schon immer gewogen
es war hart für sie sagten du nimmst
wieder zu sie beschlossen wir das
treffen wegzunehmen das ich für unsere
kirche organisiert hatte ich hatte alles
selbst in die wege geleitet sie haben
das getan um mich zu bestrafen
oft manipulierten sie ihre angestellten
in ein schuldgefühl gingen
und wie steht es mit den
anstellungsbedingungen sehr gut bezahlt
doch die kleinen angestellten verdienen
nicht viel
man erwartet von uns dass wir viele
unbezahlte überstunden machen von den
leuten die an die treffen gehen werden
zehn bis 15 prozent weight watchers
angestellt
doch diese leute
ausgesetzt schlecht behandelt und nicht
anständig bezahlt sie gehen und kehren
nie mehr zu weight watchers zurück sie
fühlen sich betrogen
genau aus diesem grund haben mehrere
tausend amerikanische angestellte zwei
klagen gegen ihr unternehmen eingereicht
wir haben uns ihre sammelklagen
angesehen
die coaches beschuldigen weight watchers
sich nicht an das mindesteinkommen zu
halten die überstunden nicht zu vergüten
und die abgangs vergütungen nicht zu
überweisen
um einen prozess zu vermeiden der dem
image enorm schaden würde hat weight
watchers eine zahlung akzeptiert knapp 8
millionen dollar 1 verkraftbarer betrag
für ein unternehmen welches jährlich
anderthalb milliarden umsatz erzielt
seither gilt das gesetz der
verschwiegenheit keiner der angestellten
hat das recht etwas über seine
arbeitsbedingungen auszusagen weder in
den usa noch in europa
wieder in der schweiz auch karin möchte
nicht über ihr salär reden doch nach
unseren informationen sind die
bedingungen ähnlich wie in den usa 20
franken pro treffen vorbereitungen und
administratives inbegriffen eine zahl
die weight watchers nicht bestätigen
wollte
karin hat eine gute ausbildung im
marketing und könnte eine viel besser
bezahlte stelle bekommen
doch sie hat angst ohne programmier 26
kilo wieder zuzunehmen jury ist nach wie
vor überzeugt dass sie ihr ziel
erreichen wird das heißt weitere 15 kilo
abnehmen dank des weltweit führenden
schlankheits unternehmens doch ihr
gewicht stagniert sie versucht es mit
einem kraftakt dem basistraining für die
teilnahme an einem lauf obwohl sie sich
mit ihrem übergewicht schaden könnte
love me auf den zehenspitzen das nicht
[Applaus]
atmet tief
wir haben bald die hälfte mehr oder
leute ich gar nicht mehr
das aufhören ich bin am ende aber gut
ich möchte es wirklich schaffen ohne
unterbruch zu laufen aber ich habe keine
kondition und jetzt tut es mir hier wie
es braucht noch mindestens 15 solcher
trainingsläufe bisher schafft von dort
bis zum auto mit normaler
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit zu laufen
gehen wann gehen schafft es ohne
anzuhalten beim rennen nicht die checks
das gar nicht ich gebe dir
wasserflaschen du läufst damit dann
sehen wir ob du noch so schnell rennst
du trägst nur 50 kilo mit ihr um das ist
nicht so wie bei mir jury hat genug
sie hat das gefühl dass die ganze mühe
nichts bringt
emily kann ihr neues gewicht gut halten
sieben kilo weniger doch ihre kleider
sind wir jetzt alle zu groß ich muss mir
neue sachen kaufen auf jeden fall eine
größe weniger
ich habe den gürtel nicht angezogen das
tue ich sonst vor allem wenn ich ausgehe
sonst muss ich die hose immer aufziehen
emily folgt dem programm akribisch sie
hat beschlossen ein für alle mal ihre
ernährung im griff zu behalten um das
jeden tag zu schaffen notiert sie genau
was sie ist auch das kleinste häppchen
zwischendurch eigentlich esse ich nicht
viel
mein problem ist das knabbern ich merke
da ein bisschen dort ein bisschen ich
frage mich warum ich jede halbe stunde
oder stunde etwas essen muss
zu realisieren dass ich erst vor einer
stunde gegessen habe das bedeutet dass
ich gar nicht hungrig bin ich habe am
mittag richtig gegessen
[Musik]
auch danny ist ziemlich zufrieden mit
seiner diät in sieben monaten hat er
sieben kilo abgenommen
[Applaus]
ich fühle mich besser weg als die
manisch ich habe mich daran gewöhnt dass
ich aufpassen muss aber wenn mir in
einem restaurant das essen wirklich gut
schmeckt genieße ich es und versuche
nicht zu übertreiben
kein zweites mal schöpfen nun
vernünftige portionen nicht kann ich
sagen dass ich mich krass teil obwohl
seine diät ziemlich gut läuft zählt der
nie seine punkte nicht er notiert sich
seine mahlzeiten ungefähr die punkte
aber vergisst er systematisch da haben
wir konnten da habe ich nicht viel
gegessen wenn ich es notiere merke ich
wenn ich an einem tag mehr es als sonst
das ist ein anhaltspunkt
vielleicht sollte ich mich strikt an das
programm halten damit ich genau weiß wie
viele punkte ich verbraucht habe aber
das ist die nächste etappe
der große tag ist gekommen obwohl sie
fast nicht trainiert hat will marge rang
aller lauf in leonding
[Musik]
zusammen mit ihren freundinnen läuft sie
in einer gruppe
[Applaus]
doch fünf kilometer laufen ist härter
als sie gedacht hat ich habe die fünf
kilometer geschafft so anstrengend ich
bin zwar nicht immer gerannt aber ich
bin angekommen das war mein ziel
marie hat ihre sportliche
herausforderung gemeistert doch
abgenommen hat sie nicht die letzte zeit
war schwierig zumal ich auch geburtstag
hatte zwei intensive wochen mit feiern
am mittwoch donnerstag freitag samstag
also ich glaube ich bin jetzt nicht auf
der linie aber das kann man ja auch
nicht immer ich sehe es positiv ich habe
gefeiert und jetzt muss ich mich eben
wieder zusammenreißen
[Musik]
wir reisen in den osten frankreichs nach
st dreimal hat sie das programm von
weight watchers mitgemacht das resultat
sie hat nicht abgenommen sondern
zugenommen
das erste mal habe ich das programm 18
monate lang gemacht und 18 kilo verloren
das war verblüffend
sogar meine betreuerin konnte es kaum
fassen
ich hielt mich sehr genau an das
programm punkt um punkt ich zählte
wirklich alle punkte und achteten strikt
darauf was auf meinen teller kamen
ich hörte mit knabbereien auf und machte
zwei bis drei stunden aquagymnastik pro
woche für meinen völlig untrainierten
körper eine echte herausforderung
das hat 18 wochen funktioniert 18 kilo
in 18 wochen ist ein brutaler
gewichtsverlust doch ihr coach bremst
sie nicht im gegenteil sie gratuliert
alexia dann wird alexa schwanger es
gelingt ihr das gewicht während der
schwangerschaft zu halten
doch nach der geburt ihres mädchens
lässt sie sich gehen
sie verliert die kontrolle ich nahm die
ganze nacht zehn kilo die ich abgenommen
hatte wieder zu und noch 784 dazu das
war mehr als damals als ich bei weight
watchers begonnen hatte
alexia will auf den rechten weg zurück
sie startet einen zweiten versuch
immerhin habe ich etwas gewicht verloren
etwa zehn kilo
aber das war hart ich habe viel länger
gebraucht wie dieser zehn kilo an einem
gewissen punkt habe ich mich gehen
lassen
es waren die festtage des
weihnachtsessen
süßigkeiten schokolade terrine all das
und nachdem ich alles zwei wochen lang
schlittern gelassen hatte gab ich auf
und sie habe wieder zugenommen
ja ich habe diese zehn kilo wieder
zugenommen und wahrscheinlich sieben
oder acht von den tag angerechnet als
ich das erste weight watchers programm
angefangen hatte bis zum schluss waren
es gut 15 km
ich habe also definitiv zugenommen
es ist schlicht gesagt eine spirale wenn
man merkt dass man sich gehen lässt
fühlt man sich irgendwie schuldig und
bei mir führt das dazu dass ich es also
hier schlechte ich mich fühle desto mehr
ist erich und je mehr ich esse desto
schlechter fühle ich mich ein
teufelskreis man fragt sich wann komme
ich endlich aus dieser spirale der
schuldgefühle und des essens heraus
kosten von über 2000 franken 15 kilo
schwerer als zuvor und ein zunehmendes
unbehagen für alexia ist die bilanz nach
dem weight watchers programm dramatisch
wir möchten wissen wie die direktion des
unternehmens solche fälle sieht wir
begeben uns zum europäischen sitz der
firma in düsseldorf die marketingchefin
empfängt uns sie lehnt es ab die
verantwortung für das scheitern
einzelner kunden zu übernehmen
ja es ist ja immer man muss ja mir den
faktor mensch auch mit einbeziehen
und es ist ja keine pille die ich nehme
und die mich schlank hält sondern das
ist eine verhaltensänderung und da muss
man natürlich dann auch den einzelnen
sehen hat er das beibehalten oder haben
sich alte routine wieder eingeschlichen
führen die kadetten sind kunden wie
alexia die große ausnahme
wir sind eigentlich was wir von unseren
kunden auch als feedback bekommen immer
sehr zufrieden
wir machen normalerweise einmal im jahr
eine zufriedenheitsstudie und fragen
dann natürlich nur wie zufrieden sind
sie mit weight watchers mit dem was wir
anbieten wie zufrieden sind sie mit
ihrer abnahme und ja das freut mich
schon dass die mehrzahl sagt also passt
über 90 prozent dass sie mindestens
zufrieden mit ihrer aufnahme sind und
das finde ich ein schönes kompliment wie
repräsentativ sind solche internen
kunden feedbacks übergewicht ist zum
problem für die volksgesundheit geworden
forscher interessieren sich für die
längerfristigen auswirkungen von diäten
ihre erkenntnisse sind alarmierend
[Musik]
2007 hat die universität von kalifornien
die zu den fortschrittlichsten in sachen
fettleibigkeit zählt eine langfristige
studie veröffentlicht diese hinterfragt
das grundprinzip der diäten nach einem
jahr sind die gewichtsverluste
spektakulär bis zu 30 kilo
aber nach vier oder fünf jahren haben
die leute wieder ihr ursprüngliches
gewicht einige wegen sogar noch mehr
wie sieht die langfristige bilanz bei
den kunden von weight watchers aus drei
jahre nach der diät das herauszufinden
ist schwierig denn das unternehmen hat
an keiner unabhängigen studie
teilgenommen
interessiert sie das nicht zu wissen was
mit den leuten nach drei jahren ist zb
wir machen da für solche ganz konkrete
zb zahlen machen wir die klinischen
studien dann wiederum die uns ja dann
auch objektiv helfen sondern
unterstützen sollen dass man sagen kann
also wenn man das durchzieht wenn man
das macht wenn man sein seine ernährung
umgestellt mehr bewegung integriert dann
habe ich auch nur dann kann ich das auch
langfristig halten und das können wir in
den klinischen studien hat immer ganz
schön belegen dass das funktioniert ich
kann halt einen kunden nach drei jahren
den sehe ich habe ständig das weiß ich
ja nicht wie lange der dann wie sein
leben weiter gelaufen ist
weight watchers klingt diese resultate
nach drei jahren als sicher ich glaube
sie sind auf dem laufen
sie selbst müssen interne studien
gemacht haben die sie aber nicht
veröffentlichen
studien die dieselben resultate zeigen
sind stellen eine gewichtsabnahme nach
einem jahr fest und das wird natürlich
publiziert das ist auch schmeichelhaft
für sie die studien über drei jahre
hingegen werden sicher nicht
veröffentlicht denn sie wären ein
schlechtes verkaufsargument dennoch sind
diese medizinisch einwandfrei belegt und
verfügten kunden dass sie sagen sie
sollen dann nach drei jahren und nach
fünf jahren noch mal bescheid sagen
warum hat man das nicht gemacht
frage in den usa nach für eine gute idee
sollte man wirklich mal machen das finde
ich eigentlich nur eine tolle sache
trotz unserer nach fragen liefert die
direktion uns keinen wissenschaftlichen
beweis ihre resultate seit jahren
ermutige ich patienten dazu diese art
von unternehmen einzuklagen wegen
unlauterer werbung oder ihre führung
denn solange keine klagen vorliegen gibt
es auch kein verbot
warum reichen die übergewichtigen
menschen keine klage ein weil sie
überzeugt sind dass der fehler bei ihnen
liegt sie fühlen sich selbst schuldig
aber wenn eine firma ein produkt
verkauft das nicht wirkt muss sie auch
die verantwortung übernehmen
aber was tun wenn eine diät nichts nützt
sind die betroffenen zum übergewicht
verdammt und vor allem dazu sich unwohl
in ihrer haut zu fühlen
nein sagt die psychologin aber oft muss
jemand an sich arbeiten und das versucht
sie mit million einer ihrer patientinnen
mann ist zuhause langweilt sich ein
bisschen aber man ist nicht unbedingt
niedergeschlagen kennen sie das
kommt ihnen das essen manchmal als
zwanghaft vor
können sie uns erklären warum weil ich
dann hinaus kann um einzukaufen
auch wenn ich meine parkplatz verlieren
wenn sie weggehen fühlen sie sich
erleichtert also legt sich der zwang
wenn sie realisieren dass sie essen
werden
unbewusst kompensiere ich die schlechte
laune mit essen wenn sie sich mit dem
gewicht befassen wie gehen sie vor
aufwärts nachweis sind folglich nehme
rasch ab wenn ich gut drauf bin dann
habe ich keine lust mehr mich voll zu
stopfen
sie brauchen also keinen druck von außen
um abzunehmen
es geht nur darum ihr gefühlsleben ins
lot zu bringen dann können sie wieder
gewicht verlieren auch ohne eigentliche
absicht wenn es einen stress problem im
leben gibt sollte man sich vielleicht
die zeit nehmen und überlegen soll ich
den job wechseln oder den partner meine
aktivitäten reduzieren mein leben anders
organisieren soll ich umziehen
manchmal liegen die ursachen von stress
und essstörungen in grundlegenden dingen
die man in frage stellen und verändern
muss damit es besser für uns passt
schlank sein ist möglich sich wohlfühlen
ist wichtig vielleicht aber auch mit ein
paar rundungen am körper emily hat ihr
etappenziel erreicht zehn kilo weniger
aber ihr gewicht stagniert seit mehreren
wochen sie senkt sich weiterhin ein um
noch mehr abzunehmen
dieses kleine bisschen macht zehn gramm
aus und wie viele punkte einen die
gefühle im griff haben ist das
schwierigste
wenn man genervt ist sollte man einen
anderen weg als das essen finden um sich
zu beruhigen
ich sage mir dann nein jetzt wird nicht
gegessen ich trinke ein glas wasser oder
gehe hinaus mache etwas anderes um
durchzuatmen
aber es gelingt mir nicht immer doch
meine ausrutscher sind seltener geworden
weil ich mich doch meistens beherrschen
kann
denn je hat zehn kilo abgenommen aber er
hat sich ein besseres resultat erhofft
ich bin eigentlich etwas enttäuscht denn
ich habe weniger schnell abgenommen als
erwartet das hat mich ein bisschen
geärgert ich habe versucht mich zu
kontrollieren habe den käse stark
reduziert auf süßes habe mich mehr
bewegt bin mehr zu fuß gegangen zum
schwimmen aber die resultate waren
bescheiden das hat mich etwas
marie hat in den letzten wochen zwei
kilo zugenommen
sie sucht fotos auf denen sie noch mehr
übergewicht hat dazu hat ihr ihre coach
karin geraten um sie zu motivieren
aber marie hat enorme sich erneut
einzuschränken
es bringt sowieso nichts
nach zwei jahren die scheiben schinken
aufzuschreiben drei löffel reis drei
punkte
wenn du mich fragst was du lieber einen
apfel oder schokoladenkuchen sage ich
schokoladenkuchen
das wird sich nie ändern sicher wäre ein
apfel besser aber das macht keinen spaß
und schmeckt weniger gut
ich bin so aufgewachsen beim essen waren
wir als familie alle zusammen am tisch
das bedeutet mir geborgenheit liebe das
zählt auch vielleicht sollte ich zu
karin gehen und das programm noch einmal
von grund auf mit machen dass sie mir
noch einmal alles erklärt auch wenn ich
da schon längst weiß ich sage nicht dass
sich coach sein könnte aber ich kenne
alle tipps weiß welche nahrungsmittel
anderen entsprechen
doch alles noch einmal von frauen zu
machen könnte vielleicht bewirken dass
ich wieder abnehmen
guten tag willkommen zu diesem treffen
wir befassen uns heute mit der
körperlichen betätigung maria sind sie
zufrieden mit dem resultat der waage ich
habe 200 gramm verloren das ist negativ
aber ich bin trotzdem zufrieden auch
wenn es gramm um gramm ist das ist
positiv also alles gut
nein es könnte besser sein aber das
dauert mit 200 kramp normal bin ich noch
einige zeit hier
am ende der dreharbeiten ist danny der
einzige der weiterhin abnimmt
emily hat schon wieder drei kilo
zugenommen und von marjorie haben wir
nichts mehr gehört
sie kommt nicht mehr zu den treffen
[Musik]